george estrada how are you i'm really
how are you what a night this is going
to be um have you actually managed to
get out on those stages yet to rehearse
yeah so we had an opportunity earlier
today to get up and soundcheck okay
i didn't really know what it was going
to look like at all so then you see
there's a few i don't know how much
people have seen but there's a few
different stages
i mean even just looking down the mouth
because we've got the kind of palace
behind us and all that it's beautiful
yeah
so when you got the call what did you
think kind of about being involved in
this over the years have you watched
jubilees with your family is it
something that you've kind of as a
family got involved with
yeah it's just surreal and i don't mean
that in a kind of like showbiz severe
way it's surreal that it's you
getting the call and then at that point
you kind of smile and
look forward to it i guess which we have
been
it is a spectacular lineup as well isn't
it who are you looking forward to i
heard queen rehearsing earlier we
watched a bit of queen rehearsals yeah
excited for that for sure and i wonder
where brian is going to perform i know
he did the roof last time so where on
earth do you go here
um
so that bud stewart for sure
because i saw mimi webb
yeah i look forward to that yeah and
you've performed everywhere all over the
world all kind of venues how does that
compare as a backdrop
i think look the thing is because even
walking to do the soundcheck you could
see a bit of the palace behind it's your
guys it's the band that makes you smile
that [ __ ] you know
then but that isn't just it because then
you get to see out the front and then
you remember people are watching at home
yeah i can't think about it too much and
it has been a difficult couple of years
for people with the pandemic and so
the people out in the mail there are
enormous numbers thousands out there it
does feel like the country wants a
reason to to celebrate doesn't it but i
went for a drive when would it have been
on wednesday or thursday
and there were some villages i couldn't
even go through because they already got
the party like tables out on the right i
don't know how you've wrangled this but
it's not just here it's everywhere
there'll be parties and
yeah celebrations and is that why it's
important for you to be involved kind of
this is about the country coming
together isn't it it's about the united
kingdom and
celebrating her celebrating us i think
things like that though so if i weren't
playing today what would i be doing i'd
be back home with the people i know and
love and raising a glass and so whatever
that celebration would be about in that
moment i guess it would differ i think
it's people having the opportunity to be
together and that's you can't ask for
more than that i don't think have you
performed for the royals before i did
the um
[Music]
royal variety once
it was prince harry do you feel like you
have to behave differently when when
there's royalty in the audience
i don't know i'm not exactly known for
my rock and roll antics so i think i'll
be fine
yeah yeah and then and the queen won't
be here tonight she's gonna be at home
probably watching on telly that's what
she's been doing with the horses and
things today um how do you feel about
her what do you think she means for the
country even just the other day i saw
this news clip of all of the prime
ministers that she's worked with and it
was churchill i know this is my
ignorance but i was like what
that's incredible but whatever you do to
to do something
and to spend that amount of time it's
incredible george ezra thank you so much
good luck that is a huge stage out there
um so yeah george ezra amongst the huge
number of acts that we're going to see
performing and it's a really nice moment
so many people have been invited i think
7 500 key workers people from charities
volunteers for the queen this isn't just
about her years of service it's about
really celebrating with the whole
country bringing people together